Baby Yoda giveth, and Baby Yoda taketh away.
CNBC is reporting that Disney's failure to
have toys based on The Mandalorian's Baby
Yoda available for the 2019 holiday season
has resulted in a loss of up to $2.7 million,
despite the fact that action figures and plushies
are available for pre-order.
"Because of all the secrecy that was surrounding
the series before it came out, Hasbro was
unable to make Baby Yoda merchandise in time
for the holidays."
The loss was a calculated one though.
The Disney+ series' creator, Jon Favreau,
has recently revealed that he was moved to
implore the House of Mouse to keep Baby Yoda
a secret up until his reveal at the end of
The Mandalorian's first episode.
He was inspired by a conversation he had on
the set of Disney's live-action The Lion King
remake with star Donald Glover, who pointed
out that these days, audiences are used to
knowing pretty much everything about every
hot new property before it's even available
to the public.
Since the element of surprise has become so
scarce, Glover reasoned, it's become a commodity.
As an example, the actor pointed to the recent
works of pop superstar Beyoncé, who has been
known to drop albums online with absolutely
no prior notice.
Not only have fans eaten them up, but the
surprise nature of these releases has sparked
as much or more discussion than any expensive
marketing push could have; in addition, the
surprise drops have the added advantage of
being, you know, free.
Favreau, rightfully sensing that he had a
breakout character on his hands with "The
Child," decided to apply this strategy in
advance of The Mandalorian's release.
It's safe to say that it worked; sure, Disney
could have easily included Baby Yoda in the
show's marketing, and the cute little bugger
may very well have taken the world by storm
in similar fashion if it had.
But The Mandalorian, the first ever live-action
TV series set in the Star Wars universe, had
already built a strong buzz just for being
the first of its kind, and by virtue of being
the most high-profile original offering available
at the launch of Disney+.
Favreau and the Mouse House basically gambled
that all eyes were going to be on the series
in any event, and that gamble paid off; little
Baby Yoda's reveal at the end of that first
episode melted hearts, sure, but it was also
a stunning surprise that we're pretty sure
no one saw coming.
"This is what was causing all the fuss?"
For one thing, it was only the second time
in Star Wars history that another member of
Yoda's mysterious species had been introduced.
For another, it was an insane plot wrinkle,
instantly altering the trajectory of the titular
bounty hunter., fans were just blindsided
by all of that cuteness; if they had known
it was coming, it still would have been cool,
but the fact that it was a complete surprise
made it the kind of "holy crap" moment that
generates buzz on the level that no mere marketing
can accomplish.
Look, $2.7 million is a lot of money by any
stretch, and the question has to be asked:
did Disney make the right decision, or should
the studio have cashed in using a more conventional
marketing campaign to introduce Baby Yoda?
Now that we've posed the query, let us answer
with a hearty laugh and the assertion that
yes, the Mouse House absolutely made the right
choice.
First of all, it stands to reason that including
Baby Yoda in the marketing push for The Mandalorian
may have set Disney back a comparable amount
of cash.
The show's shooting schedule may have had
to be shuffled around to make sure that certain
shots would be available for marketing materials,
different one-sheets from the ones we got
would have to have been produced, and additional
funds would have to have been shelled out
to advertising types to develop a marketing
strategy for the little tyke, just off the
top of our heads.
Second, the fact that toys weren't available
for the holiday season doesn't mean that those
who want them won't purchase them when they
are available.
Heck, when Baby Yoda plushies showed up for
pre-order on Disney's online store, the allotted
number initially made available sold out in
a matter of hours.
Disney was prepared for the character's popularity;
by the time Baby Yoda action figures and toys
are widely available between March and May
of 2020, everybody who wants one will be able
to get one, and that basically means literally
everybody.
Finally: $2.7 million may be a lot of money,
but to Disney, it's freaking pocket change.
This is the studio that released Avengers:
Endgame last spring, and that flick made $2.7
billion.
The movie was one of six Mouse House releases
to make more than a billion bucks in 2019.
Its theme parks and merchandise generate billions
in revenue every year; Disney+ picked up 10
million subscribers on its first day.
Disney is doing just fine.
No, we're thinking that the approach to Baby
Yoda's marketing was absolute genius, and
it's all down to a pleasant conversation that
Favreau and Glover had, discussing Beyoncé
on their coffee break.
Now, if Queen Bey's next surprise video would
feature a dancing Baby Yoda, we'd really have
something.
We're pretty sure we're the first to have
that idea; we'll take a nice fruit basket
as a thank you or $2.7 million.
Whichever is easiest.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.